People took what happened to George
Floyd and grafted that onto a
larger, broader narrative
to make the case that this is
actually endemic to American police.
The statistics just aren't there.
If you look at things like deadly
police, use of force is incredibly
rare occurrence.
The killing of George Floyd and
Breonna Taylor in 2020 touched
off a summer of protests over police
brutality, especially toward
African-Americans and Hispanics.
Too many the killings cemented as
fact a narrative that began with the
2014 death of Michael
Brown in Ferguson, Missouri, and
has found expression in highly
charged slogans such as All
Cops are Bastards and Defund
the Police. Reformers charge
that cops, far from keeping the
peace, are simply the most visible
agents of white supremacy that
systematically surveil some punishes
racial and ethnic minorities.
Long stalled reforms such
as abolishing qualified immunity
and ending cash bail, made big
gains as massive crowds
marched under the banner of Black
Lives Matter.
But what if the narrative that
police are increasingly dangerous,
violent and unaccountable
is wrong.
In Criminal [In]Justice
Rafael A. Mangual argues that police
violence is in fact rare and
declining.
He says that the criminal justice
reforms favored by social justice
activists and many libertarians
will make life worse for communities
of color.
If we're going to have an honest
conversation about where reform
needs to happen, we have to be
realistic about what the real scope
of the problem is, because that's
the best way that we're going to be
able to assess what can actually
fix that problem, what we can
reasonably expect to be the results
from those efforts.
Mangual works at the Manhattan
Institute, the New York City think
tank that played a foundational role
in the shift in policing tactics
that began in the early 1990s.
The Manhattan Institute published
the work of George L Kelling and
James Q Wilson on broken windows
policing and championed the
development of the crime tracking
program CompStat under New York
City Police Commissioner William
Bratton.
Mangual grew up in Brooklyn in Long
Island, the half Dominican half
Puerto Rican son of a New York
Police Department detective.
He attended Baruch College in the
City University of New York system
and holds a law degree from
Chicago's DePaul University.
Reason talked with him about the
facts and rhetoric surrounding law
enforcement, whether violent crime
is actually rising, and what are
the best ways to keep the peace
without harassing and locking
up innocent people.
Rafael Mangual, thanks for talking
to Reason.
Thanks so much for having me.
What is the elevator pitch for
Criminal [In]Justice?
I guess the best the basic elevator
pitch is the the book
interrogates the dominant narratives
that have been driving our criminal
justice reform debate in this
country.
It explores to what degree
is the accusation that
America has an overincarceration
problem, a police violence problem
overstated?
And how does that overstatement
lead to policies that perhaps
are misguided? What's the downside
risk associated with that policy
agenda, and who does it
disproportionately fall on?
Well, the reason I asked that last
question is because the
narratives and the debate about
criminal justice reform in the
U.S. has been largely
driven by concerns for
discrete communities that
bear the brunt of the costs
associated with the kind of robust
enforcement programs that have been
criticized.
So, I mean, you're talking about
black and Hispanic or Latino
populations.
And mostly young male, black,
Hispanic.
You know, I guess why don't we start
with George Floyd, right?
Because that's the,
you know, the immediate trigger
point of the past couple of years.
What you
know, what what is wrong about
the narrative coming out of George
Floyd's death at the hands
of police?
Yeah. You know, what are the main
strains that are like, okay,
this is wrong because, I mean, we
we all saw what we saw, which is
horror cops indifferently,
kind of killing a guy who was
subdued.
Yeah. It was a power trip, right?
I mean, it was. It was an absolute
power trip. It was something that I
have not yet spoken to
a police officer who watched
that video and wasn't equally
horrified.
I think the biggest thing that that
the narrative about that incident
gets wrong is that
it is largely characteristic
of policing in the United States.
People took what happened to George
Floyd as they have taken other
controversial police uses of force
and grafted it, grafted that onto
a larger, broader narrative
to make the case that this is
actually endemic to American
policing. And that couldn't be
further from the truth.
The statistics just aren't there.
If you look at things like deadly
police use of force, it is
incredibly rare occurrence.
It happens every day in
this country, which makes it sound
like it happens a lot.
But you have to contextualize that
reality.
Can you put. Yeah, put some numbers
on that. Yeah.
You know, what is what is the amount
of police violence versus
the amount of interactions with
police? And is the rate
going up or going down or staying
the same?
It's gone down significantly.
I mean, you know, just using NYPD
as as an example, in 1971,
which is the first year that the
department started keeping track of
their use of force statistics, they
shot more than 220 people.
That number is down to, like, a
dozen.
So significant progress with respect
to that.